welcome back to New Roar I'm Jessica
Clemens here to break down the latest
trailer to what if season 2 The Nine
episodes are dropping one at a time from
December 22nd to December 30th allegedly
the order will look like this December
22nd what if nebula joined the Nova
corpse December 23rd what if Peter Quill
attacked Earth's Mightiest Heroes
December 24th what if happy Hogan Saved
Christmas December 25 what if Iron Man
crashed into the grandmas December 26
what if Captain Carter fought the Hydra
stomper December 27th what if the
Avengers assembled in 1602 December 28th
what if hel found the 10 rings and
December 29th what if Gori shaped the
world and December 30th what if strange
Supreme intervened I say allegedly
because it might be shifting around but
the titles I think are still solid like
Eric said in the last Whata If trailer
breakdown the show is not a disconnected
Marvel Spotlight animated show it's MCU
Canon and not just because Peggy Carter
showed up in the live action Multiverse
of Madness so just just keep that in
mind and please support our Channel
further with our for all time always
shirt of Loki with the igel world tree
at the nerd rot. shop it's sick as hell
okay let's just get into this so the
trailer opens with the water and Peggy
Carter in New York City specifically
they're in Central Park and that's the
New York City skyline baby how do I know
it's Central Park that's Bridge number
28 AKA Gothic Bridge tons of movies and
TV shows shot here like elf which we
have a breakdown on on our Channel we'll
put the link somewhere below me also
Enchanted lot of Marvel movies and TV
shows at the New York landmarks The
Watcher says let me tell you one of my
favorite U tide stories that's my
impression of him and it's not good so
we know we're about to get into some
Marvel holiday nonsense the camera
swivels from the Autumn Leaves of
Central Park to the dark atmosphere at
the end of time to Loki's IG Delle tree
decorated with Christmas lights and
ornaments and God I bet he's
disappointed and the indignity that is
so rude we saw this scene right here
last in the trailer Eric mentioned this
is Hela walking in the rain up to the
antler headpiece this would be from
episode 7 what if Hela found the 10
rings then with the quickness at the
same shot the same anger but standing in
the rain with the faded teal colors is
nebula we know the first episode is
December 22nd what if nebula joined the
Nova Corp I assume this is the Nova Corp
helmet from the last trailer where we
saw nebula stepping toward yondu's body
than taking off her helmet this feels
like the same shot just you know
shortened same anger and I love these
cuts of the angriest women in the MCU
it's Gamora she's looking to be like
kneeling and whatever light is beaming
on her face must be from a prison like
cuff door it's a perfect slit or maybe a
pilot ship door is closing from the
background being desolate and the cement
flooring I feel like she's being
isolated right now and she's an ardian
armor then we get to Thor also angry
very very angry trailer this looks like
a shitari scepter that Loki uses it
could be the staff before the Mind Stone
was placed in it then we cut to a very
festive Tony Stark a very angry angry
festive Tony Stark on the phone he looks
to be on a Santa's throne with a fake
mustache and beard falling off so he's
probably playing Santa somewhere I
assume this is an episode two or three
what if happy Hogan Saved Christmas and
I think our next clip is in the same
episode which is Avengers Tower and a
snow globe I think this is a decoration
as you can see the tree branches and
festive stuff on the sides but could you
imagine if Wanda or someone uses their
magic and puts them into like a snow
globe like strange did toola and
kilmonger in episode 9 that would be
horrible we cut to Scott Lang saying
Al's all BR Chin Chin which is a toast
it means cheers and Mandarin now this is
when it gets funky and I kind of love it
it's clearly an Old Tavern the wooden
Rafters the Venetian type windows and
Decor this could be Morse head or
probably tyru from the 1602 comics in
the background a man and a woman are
also having a drink this man has either
a shield or a cloak on but the woman
looks like Peggy Carter I think this is
the scene we see later in the trailer
this could be Steve or it could be
Captain Britain Peggy and The Watcher
seem to be big parts of the trailers
closing with them in the first trailer
and opening with her in this one it
feels like she could be looking into her
own variant life or it could just be in
existence with her and Steve existing in
1602 from the last trailer we see
Ant-Man and then the same get up
fighting with the sword alongside the
Steve or Captain Britain still waiting
to see by the shield then it says 12
hulks of Smashing there's only Nine
episodes but if this isn't just a
holiday word play maybe we can see Hulk
shehulk Hulk son or different versions
of Hulk 12 separate times I'm talking
Hulk serum Hulk Offspring giant green
monsters who are jokingly referred to as
Hulk but then it cuts to the bearded
Hulk literally smashing the hell out of
a 162 Soldier Hulk is not wearing his
normal Hulk pans but these button up
pantaloons are given a different time
period the background is also a
cathedral like arches this could very
well be a church they spend a lot of
time in the Inquisition Towers in the
comics of 16002 so this could be there
cut to 11 Howard's quacking Howard the
Duck making his return the most beloved
background character in the MCU I'd say
then we see Howard in this too good so
nice Rambo esque look the Red Scarf the
bullets draped over the shoulder and a
giant gun and this gun looks like the
one from the OG Howard the Duck movie
and boy if it is I'll just scream the
gun blasts are Illuminating Light so
bright it's beaming off the top of his
little duck head but the colors are blue
and I'm keeping that noted just because
we can piece together the episodes a
little bit easier then we get to 10
rings of glowing we know that that's the
10 Rings baby we know hela's episode
what if Hela found the 10 rings but this
looks like w woo from the last trailer
where he's fighting Odin the episode is
called Hela found the 10 Rings doesn't
mean that she discovered them I say this
because he's also wearing the clothes he
wore at the beginning of shangi when he
took over the castle and claimed it in
the name of the 10 Rings this scene cuts
to Odin getting punched Square in the
face with the power of the 10 rings but
all of this makes me wonder if we're
including including the Snippets we got
from the first trailer this scene which
probably takes place in the same spot it
looks like Hela is actually just
fighting her father and I believe with
the training and what I assume is taow
in the first trailer she still becomes
evil and works with W wo to take it over
maybe like shangi she ran away from her
father found Tallow and alongside W Wu
is fighting to conquer everything in
Ragnarok that's what she wanted Odin
wanted to stop it imagine the plot of
shuni but if shanii just turned into a
bad guy I'm sure there's a lot of
theories to be made but it wouldn't make
sense Cena as Hela without consent is
controlling the great protector later in
the trailer she's not only pooping in
here with cultural appropriation she's
colonizing our Gods then it says Nine
episodes we see more cyborg rocket from
the last trailer hopping on the shoulder
of a dark elf with a bionic suit it does
look like the collector's Vault but what
really gets me is we had Howard the
duck's Rambo and this is giving
Terminator it's solely from the one red
eye but also being a cyborg this looks
like Groot or another floral Colossus in
the background with a ton of cyborgs as
well this scene looks like the same
background from stranger scene in the
first trailer everyone fighting this
could be the finale episode what if
strange Supreme intervened someone
really does need to intervene it's it's
just chaotic everything's happening
everywhere someone needs to clean it up
a mysterious Vault teeming with danger
and wonder has opened are you ready to
embark on this secret journey to explore
the relics and ruins now Magic the
Gathering is letting you take on the
role of legendary Explorer L coft with
their new secret lir collaboration this
secret lair drop is awesome it's got fan
favorite cards like Shadow Spear and
Academy ruins with Tomb Raider inspired
Art Plus an allnew mechanically unique
Laura Croft Tomb Raider card this drop
is available exclusively through the
secret website it's got six cards total
plus a treasure token and even better
the secret lair Tomb Raider drop is
available now just click the link in the
description below and get yours today
then in drops cohor this episode will
explore what would happen if the tesak
fell to Earth and landed in The
Sovereign honi Confederacy before the
colonization of America if this is her
landing on a colonizing ship I will
freak out I will eat this episode up we
see her fighting them later on land so
she'll probably be taking these ships
out one by freaking one God I'm excited
for her episode we see a shot later of
Kori stopping what might be by we see a
lot of desolate places but not really
with this sky here so I'm wondering if
this is a different realm or place she's
training with her powers if she's
messing up ships in the trailer she
better be prepared so she has to lift
these giant bison I think she's just
training then we see Ant-Man on a bunch
of little flying ants now remember from
the last trailer we're looking at Hank
Pimp's Ant-Man from the 80s and this is
the scene from episode what if Peter
Quill attacked Earth's spest Heroes and
we already see in 80s Peter Quill he's
taking the small raccoon plushy at the
carnival the lights in the background of
this scene are from that said Carnival
then oh baby I I kind of went crazy for
this we see Red Skull in
these old medieval clothes and I'm so
into this this is the same scene we got
from Hulk earlier in the trailer he's
wielding two medieval war axes I think
he's fighting the 1602 Bucky and I think
this is Bucky and not Tony Stark because
of the blue eyes but also the pattern on
his arm is on the same arm as his bionic
one and it also has the same gold print
to The Ridges of that arm fighting Red
Skull just seem so fun in medieval times
Voss speculated that this scene is in
the same realm as Scarlet Witch scene
from the first trailer and the 1602
Comics they have a lot going on
especially in like kind of Side Stories
and mutants we see a lot of different
people fighting for different things and
the same things and this could be the
convergence of those people fighting in
the comics I know we are protecting the
queen for like a good chunk of it this
could be them protecting the queen she
dies then we see where the title holiday
word play for this trailer comes from
Darcy stands in front of two large men
who look completely irritated with her
you can see at the bottom both men are
holding her arms so she's absolutely a
hostage right now on Christmas Even oh
then we get a winking Thor and a Santa
hat we've now seen two Avengers in Santa
hat so they're probably appearing in the
happy Hogan Saves Christmas episode we
see the Nova suit for nebula and she's
putting on Yu's headpiece so she's
controlling the hell out of that Arrow
but also prepped with Nova cor skills
I'm wondering if the Nova cor
intercepted yandu or yandu is just doing
some like petty ass crimes on xandar The
Watcher says there are infinite stories
to be told I can't do the voice then we
cut to searer so Ragnarok must happen we
remember that from the movie in this
episode with hella finding the 10 rings
only gets more and more mysterious with
the clips we see does she defeat him but
Ragnarok must happen maybe they lost
lost Asgard and they're looking for a
new home there's just so many theories
now that we see him wielding his like
fire sword smashing it into whatever is
the ground we know from the last trailer
in voss's Breakdown that Bucky is
included in the 80s Avenger lineup along
with Hank Pimp's Ant-Man the D Michael
Douglas from the Ant-Man prologue Wendy
Lawson StarForce that's Anette Benny
scientist character from the 2019
Captain Marvel film black panthers King
tachaka tala's father from the 1991
prologue in Oakland and black panther
the first movie Bill Fosters Goliath and
Thor a lot of 80s references and people
in this season of what if Rambo Howard
Terminator rocket they literally have
the most popular like icons of the 8S on
the team all you're kind of missing is
wiona Rider at this point then the
Watcher starts shuffling the breaking
glass what separated him from the
universe that Ultron Vision broke
through last season we see The Shard of
Thanos and The Collector then I know I
was freaking out about red school cohor
but this is my number one freak out we
see a poker table and it's Groot corg
and meek with a little hat slicing
they're playing rock paper scissors this
is truly the funniest thing I've ever
imagined rock paper scissors with the
embodiment of like the real Rock the
real paper and with meat with those like
meat Cleavers that that represents
scissors they're also just wearing basic
Casino wardrobes nothing too close to
what we've seen in Black Panther or even
madra for but this is absolutely a
casino where they're playing rock paper
scissors with themselves because we hear
him later we see him returning for the
Christmas episode as Sam Rockwell's
Justin Hammer we'll see his Jolly ass
and happy saving Christmas most likely
but who is he saving Christmas from this
Grinch who might be literally stealing
gifts right now in the trailer we see
the Christmas tree and Iron Man socks
and let me tell you no one wants socks
for Christmas it's been said I'm saying
it right now you'll never get me the
right size I have big ass feet Thor is
going against The Rock egos we saw in
the trailer I'm sure in this universe
ego is currently planting himself on
different planets just like he did
before he just has quill helping him
this time I assume ego is doing most of
the planting and not quill because the
dirt warriors on the terrain look like'
80s Kurt Russell ego another 80s icon
returning in 8s 4 what are we doing here
but Muir is thrown through a cut scene
into this orange red area this could be
Odin he has the same forearm Shield like
like armor and we know that he's one
amongst like five people that can wield
M near then we cut to happy with some of
Tony's iron Legion suits with the
Christmas lights in the background
they're probably helping happy during
Christmas doing Patrol or just setting
up Odin then shoots his sword to the
heavens and unleashes a blast of fire it
feels like when he used Moler to cast th
out of Asgard in the first movie but
this blast is pointed up it could be at
cter it could be against W woo this is
all kind of still up in the air because
we're not getting a lot of shots of like
what he's aiming at what he's doing it
could be when w woo comes down on him
you could blast him into space then what
everyone was waiting for what if strange
Supreme intervene this is probably
strange Supreme just intervening the
wallpaper from this episode looks like
they could be in the sanctum sorum he
could be messing up someone else in that
world a close-up of korti using her
power is like a badass I'm genuinely so
so excited for her episode I cannot wait
for this episode we see Tony from the
episode of what if Iron Man crashed into
the grandmas Tony Stark in his makeshift
Hulkbuster armor then another from Happy
Saves Christmas of another Avenger in
Christmas gear this looks like Captain
America is an elf so we have the scene
of Tony as Santa and Steve as an elf I
think we're focusing on the basic
everyone knows Christmas looks and I'm
sure we'll get like a nutcracker or
reindeer next you know those common ones
I also can't tell what he's dodging I
think they edited it out so it's going
to be a surprise then I cussed a Chaka
battling ego's Rock people Captain
Carter comes down with her shield and
what looks like the forest but I think
this is the scene from the opening in
Central Park then Thanos steps out of
this like blue purple portal and space
reaching out his Infinity Gauntlet it
looks like he has all the stones but the
middle one which is the space Stone
which we know in this season cahor would
have we see in the first trailer a scene
of Captain Carter trying to step between
cahor and Thanos so he's come for those
stones then we get Justin Hammer being a
dumb dumb in Tony's Hulkbuster outfit so
the last time we saw Justin was like I
believe in the Marvel's one shot all Hil
the king he's in prison reading pepper
Forbes interview if we play along those
lines he must have got out of prison and
like reached the Avengers and I fighting
them during Christmas I understand that
these all come out around Christmas but
only one episode says Christmas in the
title so I assume any of the Christmas
references are in the same episode Darcy
being held hostage happy and the iron
Legions elf Cap Santa Thor and Tony are
all going to be in the same episode with
Justin in the Hulkbuster suit cuz that's
the Christmas episode this is what I'm
assuming this is what I assume and
that's it for our second trailer
breakdown on what if season too there's
so much going on a lot of this stuff was
in the first trailer but there are a
little bit of little extra little extra
nuggets in there for us we're all
getting ramped for the holidays even
Marvel is so I can't wait to see all
those episodes drop one at a time and me
to tell my mom to hush up when I'm
watching it follow us on Instagram and
Twitter follow me on Instagram at
Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
I'll see you in the
[Music]
holidays